SPEAKER: When working
with the cloud,
many companies assume
you're trading off
control for scalability.
Thanks to Google Cloud's
new Bare Metal Solution,
you can run your
specialized workloads
on Bare Metal servers
with full privileges
while having them
directly connected
to your cloud environment.
This gives you the
best of both worlds,
letting you modernize your
applications while still
maintaining the investments
you've made in an existing
architecture.
Let's take a look at migrating
an Oracle database to the Bare
Metal Solution and
adding more functionality
through Google Cloud Services.
When you sign up for Google
Cloud's Bare Metal Solution,
you'll have two environments--
your Google Cloud environment
hosting your applications
and your Bare Metal Solution
in the region extension.
These two are connected with
Cloud Interconnect, giving you
a direct and low latency
connection between them
and with all servers appearing
in the same network construct.
Let's simplify and
break our application
into the front end and
the Oracle database.
We can take the front
end and migrate directly
to Google Cloud using
Compute Engine to run
on virtual machines.
We'll then migrate
our Oracle Database
to the Bare Metal server.
The architecture
would look like this
with different subnets
for each environment
but still able to communicate
over Interconnect.
The VMs running
on Compute Engine
can directly interface
with your database
while still being able to
access other Google Cloud
Services, like Cloud
Storage, letting you capture
the benefits of both worlds.
Now let's see it in action
with a sample migration.
We'll start with a networking
page in the Google Cloud
console, where you can
see our current VPC
network for the Compute
Engine instances.
Now we can head to the
Compute Engine page
to see our instances and connect
to one through the browser SSH
tool.
Since these two
environments are connected,
we can jump to the Bare
Metal Solution server
from our virtual machine.
In this case, we'll run the SSH
command to directly hop over.
In addition, we could
also connect over
any number of protocols
if we set them up,
allowing just about any
specialized workload
to be migrated.
Before we do the
example migration,
let's make sure everything looks
good by running top and seeing
that we have full access to
all our Bare Metal machines
resources.
This is a physical
machine, and we're
running Red Hat Enterprise,
so you can manage software
the same way you do with
your on-prem servers,
like with the Yum
package manager.
We also have the
benefit of the cloud,
so we'll use the Google
Cloud command line
interface right on the machine.
We can run gsutil to
download an Oracle RMAN
backup uploaded from
on-premise onto the machine.
After that, we can run
the short script, which
creates a database,
then imports the data.
If you have a gold
image of your database,
it's now possible to spin
up multiple dev environments
and have them all connected
to your cloud resources.
This solution also works for
real application clusters,
letting you manage high
availability setups.
Now that the database
has been restored,
let's take a look at the data.
Since both environments have
direct access to each other,
you can run the same tools
you're already familiar with,
such a SQL Developer.
We can see here that the
database has been restored,
and our application
can connect directly.
Once again, the Interconnect
lets your cloud apps
communicate with the Bare Metal
server in any number of ways.
Now that we've seen
how you can migrate,
let's try to enrich the
data with other Google Cloud
Services.
We'll start by exporting the
data from our running database.
Once again, we can use gsutil.
But this time, we'll
upload the file
from our Bare Metal machine
to Google Cloud Storage.
You could also set up
streaming over Interconnect,
but we'll keep it simple for
now by just using a file.
Let's switch back to
the Google Cloud console
and head to BigQuery.
With the Oracle Database export
uploaded to Cloud Storage,
it's easy to query the
data from BigQuery,
giving you the ability to
run large analysis jobs.
You can see a preview
of the data that's
been exported from the
database, and you can even share
the table with other users.
BigQuery also connects to many
other tools like Data Studio,
giving you an easy way
to visualize the data.
We can switch to Data Studio and
quickly build a visual report
of our application data.
If we had set up streaming
between the Oracle
Database and BigQuery,
these reports
would be automatically updated
with new data as it comes in.
In addition, you can also
load your cloud storage data
into other tools
like AI Platform
to build custom ML models.
By connecting the cloud
to Bare Metal servers,
you can modernize your
specialized workloads
with minimal disruption on
top of being able to innovate
with Cloud Services.
If you're interested in
learning more, visit this URL
and contact your sales team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]